[Musik]
wie machen wir das die suche nach nagoya
und wie sollen wir für stinkende einfach
dem geruch nach düsseldorf
[Musik]
wie klingt ein bisschen wie schlimm wird
ja auch mal für die beine hoch 18 euro
gefallen wien 18 euro und liegt
angeblich noch bevor wir müssen erstmal
auf veränderte dem verschwinden wieder
für leute wir haben es jetzt einen tag
später die vorfall tiefgekühlt wird sie
eigentlich in die elbe soll nicht gibt
ich wollte euch gern noch mal zeigen
könnt ihr das gesehen ich habe für diese
eine frucht 17 eur 63 geteilt oder
privat ist ein guter preis für eine
leckere frucht aber anscheinend stinkt
dieses films ist ich hab ein bisschen
schritt ich habe schon videos gesehen wo
leute sich übergeben haben bei die
düssel übergeben weil diese schlimme
stunden hat oder geschmeckt hat ich weiß
es nicht auf jeden fall als luca schon
angekündigt dass er selbst nicht
probieren wird ein malblock an dieser
stelle ja wir haben gestern den
verkäufer gefragt wie man die öffnet
weil das bild radikal verfeinerten ihrer
der wichtigkeit als gucke ich jetzt
meine hände an seine handflächen normal
ich drücke ein bisschen dagegen dass ein
gefühl dafür kriegt ihrer natürlichen
also die frucht ist ultra fahrer mittels
bist du tanzen und jetzt leute beginnen
wir also man sagt einschnitt hier
entlang dieser stelle machen
ihr wisst schon offen gefesselt kann
passieren dass jetzt anfängt zu stinken
okay bob was der fertigt ohne reiter
eine folie außerdem obst oder sucht
leute bevor ich mich geöffnet
schulz nur für euch das video war als er
das war schon gegriffen
die leute werfen wird heute hatte ich
gerade das fühlt sich anbieten hat man
leute die das badehaus stück das wär
doch was meint ihr ja wahrscheinlich
denkt gar nicht kann mich scheiße
aufgeholt hier sterben gibt ihre anderen
händen frucht die ich hier gesehen habe
2000 jahre später macht immer noch
lieben schweiz und öl das aufeinander
leute da ist eine hohe min war das nicht
wahr dass die stimmigste frucht der welt
der richtige button sitzt er auch noch
ein wurm drin macht viel spaß bei metten
das ding ist die frucht ist riesengroß
er verwertet gleich trotzdem probieren
also leute das hier definitiv mich essen
erste wurm drin
das dritte wurden die leute ohne spaß
leider aufnahmen gerade von der
fruchtbaren tage sieht schon gelb roten
karte guck dir mal hatte ich schneide
diese dinge für einmal wird durch iris
in klammern gesagt aus was denn
überhaupt davon wird macht der masse
abheben
mag man heute dieses video hochgeladen
mit dieser jugend ruft ich habe der
schokoladenverzehr gemacht leute dieses
stück ist in dieser frucht der schwinger
angeklagte hält
das ding ist diese frucht ist den
asiatischen ländern teilweise verboten
in öffentlichen transportmitteln weil
die wirklich stimmt der veranstaltung zu
wenig abgeschreckt wie genau sich dafür
die schwimmern schlimmer hätt de fliger
warum kocht man nicht jeder sondern ich
habe gefragt nur so wenig kennt ihr
diese für europa wahrscheinlich nur ein
bisschen unangenehmen geruch wenn man
irgendwo zwischen supermarkt
eingerichtet hat es um bestimmte not
schmeckt so mal 1000
[Musik]
auf jeden fall heute nicht mehr leute
vorbei ins rechte eck das video ab heute
in kraft wenn ihr experiment heute dann
probiert mal ausländer die gelegenheit
gehabt aber das war für mich das letzte
mal wo es ist klasse dass